welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and this is explained the show where
we explain the hidden agenda behind each
episode of Rick and Morty because if
it's one thing Rick and Morty fans love
it's a new way to explain to their
friends what it's all really about now a
reminder to subscribe to the Rick's
plain podcast feed wherever you get your
podcast so you'll have access to the
official Rick and Morty after show of
new rock stars as we wait for season 4
to come out we're looking at one
standout episode from each season for
season two the episode that encapsulates
the overall themes best is auto-erotic
assimilation the episode in which Rick
reconnects with an old flame a hive mind
named unity and ends the episode with a
bleak suicide attempt I'm gonna sit down
with the writer of this episode Ryan
Ridley in a few minutes but first let's
look at autoerotic assimilations three
acts to explore its deeper metaphor I
believe that unity actually represents
Rick and Morty co-creators Dan Harmon's
past sitcom community community was Dan
Harmon sitcom on NBC about a study group
at a community college it was known for
subverting the traditional sitcom
formula with genre-bending episodes and
fantasy escapades one of the best shows
on TV during that era community got a
huge reference in this Rick and Morty
episode Rick uses unities hive mind to
play God with a TV show no make him all
make fun of the blond one now make him
I'll do it on the table it's referring
to Britta of community and when she and
Jeff banged on the study group table
Rick cancels the show then puts it back
on then cancels it again all which did
happen with community and we actually
see a version of the community cast on
the TV but like Rick with unity Dan
Harmon has also spoken about his
unhealthy obsession with working on the
show community a show that he was fired
from after its third season but then
later got a chance to return to it for
its fifth season in sixth season on
Yahoo screen act 1 of this episode
reintroduces rick to unity and brick
faces the uncomfortable truth that many
of us face that often our exes are so
much better off after they leave us
since breaking up with Rick unity has
assimilated an entire planet and
achieved world peace she's well on her
way to her goal of assimilating the
whole universe and becoming a god but
this goes even deeper than just a
metaphor for breakups and the success of
exes in my opinion in 2013 after Dan
Harmon went through the breakup with
community he said on his harmontown
podcast that watching the new season
that was made without him by new
showrunners
was like quote flipping through
Instagram just watching your girlfriend
blow everyone and seeing a friend like a
photo of your ex-girlfriend with her new
boyfriend on Facebook and I shouldn't
have to point this out but a unity
community unity is community without
become munication what do you think I
was gonna say Act two features Rick
hooking back up with his ex having all
kinds of reckless orgy sex with hundreds
of redheads and a stadium packed with
people who look like Rick's dad and drug
binges that lead to unity nuking pieces
of itself this can be seen as the period
Hartmann returned to community in 2014
for season five in a sixth season that
aired on Yahoo screen in 2015 allowing
Harmon and his fans to somewhat achieve
the long clamored for six seasons in a
movie auto-erotic assemble a ssin was
written during that final season of
community which is what made that meta
joke of Rick playing God with the TV
show so relevant he says no cancel it
okay now put it back on haha
all right I'm bored we could see this as
harmon losing his passion in those later
seasons of community after he returned
to it and then Rick rants about his
grandkids to unity saying just put you
at the center of their lives because
you're powerful and then because they
put you there they want you to be less
powerful never gonna happen though right
the fact that the community actors get
the punchline here proves it this is
Herman himself airing his frustration
about creating a world of characters for
NBC and Sony with community just to have
them fire him because they want to
control over him and then finally in the
third act of the episode unity leaves
Rick and he accepts the truth about his
influence on her being toxic and that he
needed select Oh even if it means he
will be alone in this world and in one
of the bleakest ever endings Rick
retires to the garage assembles a
suicide machine and prepares to vaporize
himself but passes out in despair at the
last second in the same way that Rick
has to let go of a hive minded populace
of adorers so did Harmon with a rabid
community fanbase and as he's discussed
in interviews and on his podcast that
separation led him to further depression
and self-destructive tendencies in a
live episode of Harmon town the guy even
joked about his hypothetical suicide
note and how he would kill himself I
said I say everybody you're off the hook
please I'm so sorry for the mess like I
wish that I could have just jumped into
a vaporizer or a Sarlacc pit I'm so
sorry
like if you're for those of you who
found it and all this
I'm so sorry in general season two is
about Rick accepting his own toxic
influence and removing himself to save
those he loves the season ends with him
surrendering himself to the Galactic
Federation as Nine Inch Nails hurt plays
and while not as bleak as suicide it's
pretty close in linking that moment to
the bleak ending of auto-erotic
assimilation we see how influential past
heartbreak was on that despair but hey
that's just my Rick's planation how
legit is it according to the insiders of
Rick and Morty well we have invited the
writer who wrote this episode Ryan
Ridley on the show to explain the
secrets behind it
right after this quick message from our
sponsors hey everyone Eric here we and
new rock stars are overjoyed to finally
be able to launch new exciting shows
like Rick's planed but really the ones
who are most to thank for helping us get
this started are our patrons over at our
patreon if you're looking for a way to
help this channel grow and do even more
new exciting projects please consider
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rock stars we have a ton of great
bonus content behind-the-scenes looks as
well as exclusive videos that we're just
providing to our patrons to thank them
so if you want to join that inner circle
and get the insider look as well as be
part of this channels ongoing success
again just check out our link in the
description patreon.com slash new
rockstars and we're back now joining
this episode of Rick's plane to help us
break down the season 2 episode
auto-erotic assimilation is the writer
of that episode Ryan Ridley thanks for
coming back Ryan thank you again for
having me and also joining this chat is
our good friend and Rick and Morty
superfan and no stranger to all things
out of erotic Sam basher boom you owned
up to that to me quickly well Ryan we
were discussing the theory of the ways
that the unity episode might parallel
Dan's
experience the other writers experience
working on community because you worked
on community as well before coming to
Rick and Morty and I'm curious like how
did the community reference in this
episode come into the script and how
much do you think Dan's relationship
with community and the community fan
base influenced the writing on Rick and
Morty what kind of say first of all
let's take a little time to acknowledge
that how good the title is fun but
exactly then that's the very point I'm
trying to make it's like does everything
have to be a Rick or Morty pun I don't
think so
yeah
if you have a good title you have a good
title it's a title that like I can't say
without smiling it with yeah that's such
a good thumbs it up perfectly god I
wonder if there is some correlation
between non pun titles in the quality of
the episode because total row and total
records upon title so I think that it's
hard for a lot of creators to not get
influenced by what fans are expecting or
what they want and there's a dangerous
path you can go down of that I'm just
going like I guess they want more of
this popular character and I am NOT a
fan of indulging that I say they love
these characters so let's not give them
more let's go to the same well these
characters came from yeah well different
well you know and and and so I don't
know so I think season 2 is when the
show became a hit I guess whatever you
metric you measure that by like it was
when suddenly it was like oh this isn't
just another Adult Swim show that you
know a bunch of goofballs are making it
was like people actually care about this
and it's breaking through into a higher
plane and of awareness and so I think
that's when it started to affect us
mm-hmm I'll just say us and suddenly it
was like things became a little less
real relaxed in the writing and suddenly
I was like no no this has to be amazing
this has to be amazing which I think
would community even though I can't
speak to the first three seasons
certainly not the four season but I
guess Dan was probably like that from
the beginning because he was like this
is my thing this is my legacy this is
how I'm gonna prove to the world you
know that I'm great and he did with that
show obviously and I don't know if Rick
had he treated Rick and Morty that way
at first I think Rick and Morty was his
friend Justin show that I you know he
was like you know it relaxed a little
bit you know any mean and then all of a
sudden Rick and Morty let's face it
eclipse
community culturally and that was
probably a difficult thing to get for
everyone especially Dan to get his head
around
did I say anything that could possibly
insult anybody good so the point is I
think that you know it was a guess to
answer the question if I am is it's just
it's it's about how much you let anyone
else besides you and your creative
collaborators influence the direction
you think a show should she go some of
the things that Rick gets to do with his
ex-girlfriend unity does feel like
there's just a lot of specific random
things like there's a moment where he
wants to have an orgy with every redhead
he can find in a stadium filled with
people who look like his dad like how
much of this do comes from like writers
like lives themselves is there any like
because I mean Dan Harmon's ex-wife is a
redhead you know like how much of this
is like inside jokes with with writers
if it's not Dan and Justin other writers
around the table I mean it was you know
that what's chicken in the egg it's why
did Dan marry redhead is the real
question the point is yeah a lot of that
stuff gets gets gets seeped in there I
mean I I I think I I'm a narcissist now
I'm not a narcissist I just realized I
don't know how to nurse one of these
things we throw our like genius like
let's try throwing this around
willy-nilly these are reserved for a
small brief less self-involved you know
like anyone so take this with a grain of
salt I grew I think I remember pitching
this idea how do you combine the big
Star Trek level episodes it's obviously
no secret that they are very it's very
borg inspired with like a really
grounded like episode of like a Showtime
show about like you know Californication
like dysfunctional a sexual visit own
narcissistic relationships you know that
kind so I was like you know we've all
had those kind of well we've all had
kept relationships of course and some
people more than others and I assume
Rick is gonna have the most [ __ ] up
relationships cuz he's an alcoholic
insane narcissistic genius and so I
thought about the idea of you know the
classic thing of your ex he tried to
kind of keep your thumb on you know and
you were happy that they were lower
status than you and and that made you
feel better about yourself
but then what happens if you run into
them later and they're as successful not
more successful or higher status or
equal status or whatever you and your
gonna start - and not only is it
whatever the chemistry that brings you
two together and the dysfunction that
brings you two together
but I think Rick you know it's fun to
like play with the idea of Rick wanting
to bring her down a few pegs
yeah and fun in a dark way yeah cuz
she's on her way to becoming a god she
said yeah she was assimilate as much to
the universe as she can and that's
exactly what Rick wants is he wants to
be God himself
Wayne states it now when you were
writing this episode did you we ever
worried about how Rick's suicide attempt
might play out or how it we might
respond to it no I mean I think at that
point especially it was a natural
extension of a lot I mean you know
season one ended with I'm in great pain
please help me revealed to be his
catchphrase so it's no surprise that he
was in great pain and eventually you
know if you don't have help
you're gonna maybe go the other way so
[Music]
yeah I mean I don't know I guess then
maybe the audience was I don't know was
that was it was the perception that that
was like holy [ __ ] i Caribbean being on
the other side of things I never really
thought of but I just like this makes
sense to me but I think that taking a
step back stylistically I think I'm a
troll or who's a writer in season two
pitched sort of like let's do like a
breaking bad style ending you know what
are these or whatever I sent no way of
saying peak TV style Mad many dramatic
endings and so I think that was kind of
the meta context for doing that and it
you know and it also makes sense it
wasn't arbitrary it was like yes he
would probably maybe drunkenly try to
kill him yeah well okay with that do you
see Rick's character at any any any
point in the 50 years of the show gonna
go on or however long him becoming
mentally healthy or as we just going to
be seeing a constant downward spiral for
his character that's a good question I
don't know I mean I I certainly don't
know I'm not involved when the current
season so I don't know what trajectory
they've decided to turn you know maybe
the most interesting ironic thing in the
world would be season four or five
whatever is Rick happy Rick I mean I'm a
big fan of Buffy the Vampire Slayer and
my favorite season was season six when
they were like let's just make everybody
in the show
sex and Buffy's up and she's she's
having a fling with spike who was like
her enemy in the first whatever two or
three four seasons and so that was such
a great departure so maybe the most
interesting departure for Rick was that
he gets healthy once he's in it
hopefully still be funny and interesting
because you know the danger is like just
being dark for dark sake and just you
know not having the characters evolve
and grow you know I mean I you know
there are certain shows that show we're
gonna go remain nameless that uh you
know you're like well just because
you're animated
doesn't mean you have to stay the same
for thirty years you know what if what
if the two main characters were divorced
what if the little baby that sucks on
the pacifier suddenly just died come on
you know switch it hmm yeah I guess
after so long I'm doing it the same way
it like then at that point you're
committed to staying on that path you
know like and feel like a betrayal
unless they do want to end it which
things should end eventually right yeah
I mean you know it's it's you know all
stories yeah it's that's the everything
like a story is something that has
whether it's a TV show or a book or a
movie like there's like this is it and
this is the you know that's the reason
why TV show finales are often like
dissatisfying because it's like always
like well this wasn't really planned as
this perfect sphere it was like so we're
just like guess this is what would
happen you know so I don't know it'd be
curious how Rick and Morty continues to
evolve and I think that's one of things
that makes like Rick and Morty unique is
most TV shows are set up just to be
repeatable duplicatable for you know six
seasons in a movie and Rick and Morty is
one it's like know these characters are
on trajectories and they are gonna
change and there are consequences like
when c-137 Rick and Morty come to the
new dimension like their graves stay
there and it comes up in a later episode
another layer so we have to dig
themselves back up you know so it's it's
interesting to see a show that like goes
for broke every episode but like has to
deal with the consequences yeah I mean
that's that's that's because it's a
reflection of real life yeah yeah I mean
you know as much as that show is absurd
it's you know at a deeper level beyond
the cosmetics
the animation and their aliens and all
that it hopefully resonates is something
that is relatable like I said the this
episode it's like that's a relationship
that I'm sure a lot of people have
experienced they don't think
specifically people involved on the show
probably experienced you know I'm not
saying that was however I experienced it
either but you know you could take a
kernel of of a feeling you've had and
extrapolate it to a character and a
scope as big as Rick yeah well great
well thanks so much Ryan for helping us
break down
auto-erotic is simple you should I can't
say that such a great title it's been so
great to have you here again and thanks
again to same passion for joining this
conversation I would say i'm on twitter
instagram at sam bachelor now we will be
back in another episode to look at the
season 3 episode of Rick and Morty the
Rick lantus mix-up
aka tales from The Citadel the return of
evil Morty everyone loves this one and
another reminder to subscribe to the
Rick's play podcast feed wherever you
get your podcasts Rick and Morty season
4 is coming soon and when it does we're
explained we'll turn into new rockstars
official Rick and Morty after show with
all kinds of exciting guests so you're
gonna want to tune in for and inside
looks to the episode information that
you wouldn't otherwise get thank you for
joining us and see you next time bye bye
[Music]